I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello everybody. Hello everybody.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了这个终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有亲历其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。大家好。
We have some news about Angela's note cards. Well, I ran out of note cards last night. She ran out of note cards, everyone. I ran out of note cards because that's how many note cards I've been using on this podcast. So I started writing on a photo paper. Oh, I see that. You kind of cut some photo paper into the side of the note card. I didn't cut it, Jenna.
我们有一些关于安吉拉的记事卡的消息。嗯，我昨晚用完记事卡了。大家听到了吧，她用完记事卡了。我用完记事卡了，因为我在这个播客里用了超级多的记事卡。所以我开始在一张相纸上写。哦，我看到了。你把一些相纸剪成了记事卡的大小。我没有剪它，珍娜。
Who do you think I am? I didn't cut it. Oh, that's for a four by six photo. What do you think I was up late last night? Oh my gosh, they're glossy. On one side and I wrote on the mat side because I wrote on the glossy side and I got Sharpie all over me. Anyways, very exciting guys.
你以为我是谁？我才没剪。哦，那是为了放四乘六的照片。你觉得我昨晚熬夜干嘛呢？天哪，它们是光面的。只有一面，我写在哑光的那一面，因为我写在光面那一面上，结果我的手上全都是记号笔。总之，大家这非常令人兴奋。
I have to go buy some note cards today. I have to go to Staples or somewhere. Staples was Dunder Mifflin's competitor. Yes. Yeah. And we got a lot of fans right in and tell us about all of the Staples merchandise that they see scattered around our set. Yeah, somebody got really like in a tizzy about it.
我今天得去买一些记事卡。我得去史泰博或者什么地方。史泰博是邓德米夫林的竞争对手。是的。对。有很多粉丝写信来告诉我们，他们在我们的片场周围看到了各种散落的史泰博商品。是的，有人对此大惊小怪的。
Do you remember? I was very upset about some Staples thumbtacks on Pam's desk, I guess. What is she doing? All right. Today, everyone, we are going to talk about the fire. Season two, episode three, written by BJ Novak and directed by Ken Qopis. Yes. Here is my first fast fact.
你还记得吗？我记得帕姆的桌上有一些史泰博图钉，当时我非常生气。她在干什么？好了，各位，今天我们要谈论的是大火。第二季第三集，由B·J·诺瓦克编剧，肯·克瓦皮斯执导。是的。这是我的第一个冷知识。
It's very short. This is the third episode from the team of BJ Novak and Ken Qopis. They teamed up on Diversity Day, they teamed up on Sexual Harassment, and now here they are again, the fire, finally tackling some rather non-controversial topics. Yes. Wait, do I look like I'm looking at you oddly? Do I look weird looking at you? What?
它非常短。这是B·J·诺瓦克和肯·克瓦皮斯这对组合合作的第三集。他们在《多元日》合作过，在《性骚扰》合作过，现在他们又来了，《大火》，终于开始处理一些相当没有争议的话题了。是的。等等，我看起来像是在奇怪地看着你吗？我看着你的时候样子很奇怪吗？什么？
Well, I'm wearing my readers so I can see my note cards. Okay. But I can't see you that well, and I wonder, because you look blurry, do I look weird looking at you or do I look normal? You aren't blinking a lot, but besides that, you look normal. Oh, you guys, I got readers. Okay, sorry. Just put them down at the end of your nose.
嗯，我戴着老花镜，这样我才能看清我的记事卡。好吧。但我看你没那么清楚，我在想，因为你看起来很模糊，我看着你的时候样子很奇怪吗，还是看起来很正常？你眨眼不多，除此之外，你看起来很正常。哦，天哪，我买老花镜了。好吧，抱歉。把它放在你的鼻尖上。
You have to do that thing. You look over the top of them at me, like that. Okay. Now she's got it, guys. Okay. That was it on the first fast fact. I mean, I said it was short. That was it.
你得做那个动作。你从眼镜上方看着我，就像那样。好吧。现在她学会了，各位。好吧，第一个冷知识就这些。我的意思是，我说过它很短。就这些。
I think that's a great fast fact. BJ and Ken made a phenomenal team and created some really, really great episodes. You know what? They're never going to team up again. That's it. This is it, guys. Why would you do that? Third and final.
我觉得这是一个很棒的冷知识。B·J和肯是一个非凡的团队，创作了一些非常非常棒的剧集。你知道吗？他们再也不会合作了。就是这样。就是这样，各位。你为什么要那样说？第三个也是最后一个。
Oh, you were like, they were so great. Yeah. And never again. And then never again. Here is fast fact number two. This was the first episode we shot when we came back from our season one hiatus. It was the fire. And I have a fan question, Latimania, I hope I said that right, Latimania asks, what was
哦，你刚才还说，他们太棒了。是的。然后就再也没有了。然后就再也没有了。这里是冷知识之二。这是我们从第一季休假回来后拍摄的第一集。那是《大火》。我有一个粉丝的问题，Latimania，希望我没读错，Latimania问，片场的氛围是怎样的？
the atmosphere like on set? What were some of the biggest changes you noticed between filming season one and season two? I thought that was a good question. It is a good question. The biggest difference was that we were no longer shooting in a real office in Culver City. We were now finally at our home on the sound stages deep, deep in the San Fernando Valley
你在拍摄第一季和第二季之间注意到的最大的变化是什么？我觉得这是一个好问题。这是一个好问题。最大的区别在于，我们不再是在卡尔ver城的真实办公室里拍摄了。我们终于来到了我们在圣费尔南多谷深处的摄影棚里的家，就在
off of Satakoy Street. So a lot of TV shows are shot on these big studio lots. You know, if you come to LA and you get like a tour of Paramount Studios or Universal, that is not where we were. That is not where we worked. Those studio lots, they have little like... Cafeterias. Yeah.
萨塔科伊街旁。所以很多电视剧都是在这些大型制片厂里拍摄的。你知道，如果你来到洛杉矶，参观派拉蒙影城或环球影城，那不是我们所在的地方。那不是我们工作的地方。那些制片厂里有像……食堂。是的。
Gift shops. What do you call those places? Gyms. A gym. I don't know. Wait, I don't go often. Clearly. I'm not quite sure what they're called.
礼品店。你们管那些地方叫什么？健身房。健身房。我不知道。等等，我不常去。显然。我不太确定它们叫什么。
What are those things called? What are those places with the muscles and the heavy things? And you walk in place for a long time. A gym. Yes. They have gyms and, oh, the Warner Brothers has its own preschool for the people who work there. Yeah, you can bring your kids and they go to preschool on the lot.
那些东西叫什么？那些有肌肉和沉重器械的地方？你还在原地走很长时间。健身房。是的。他们有健身房，哦，华纳兄弟公司为在那里工作的人们自己的幼儿园。是的，你可以带你的孩子去，他们在片场的幼儿园上学。
There are all these bells and whistles when you work on a lot. We did not. We worked in this very industrial area and on a dead end street, there was definitely no coffee shop. There was. There was no gym. There was definitely no gym. We were across from a train track.
当你在片场工作时，有各种各样的附加福利。我们没有。我们在一个非常工业化的区域工作，在一个死胡同里，绝对没有咖啡店。有。没有健身房。绝对没有健身房。我们在铁轨对面。
Yeah. And like, was there like a junkyard? Yeah. It was like a car scrap towing yard. And so we would see people in the mornings, very angry, come to claim their towed car and if they didn't come, they would sell them for scrap. There was like usually a line of just really ticked off people. And then on my commute, I remember like right before I would turn left to go on our street,
是的。而且，有什么废品场吗？是的。就像是一个汽车报废拖车场。所以我们在早晨会看到一些非常愤怒的人来认领他们被拖走的汽车，如果他们不来，他们就会把它们当废品卖掉。通常有一排非常生气的人。然后在我通勤的路上，我记得就像在我左转进入我们街道之前，
I would sit at this red light and there was a mortuary, like where you go to be cremated. Yeah. That was my morning commute. It was like, it was very industrial. The crazy thing is that during the break before we came back to shoot, I got a guest job on that 70s show. Oh, and they were fancy. Fancy doesn't even begin to describe it.
我会遇到这个红绿灯，那里有一家殡仪馆，就是那种去火化的地方。是的。那是我的早晨通勤。它就像，非常工业化。疯狂的是，在我们回来拍摄的假期期间，我得到了一个在《那七十年代秀》客串的工作。哦，他们很高级。高级甚至不足以形容它。
Really? Give me the dish. All right. So they were on a lot. They had a coffee shop that served Starbucks coffee. Wow. Yeah. They had a gym.
真的吗？跟我八卦一下。好吧。所以他们在摄影棚里。他们有一家提供星巴克咖啡的咖啡店。哇。是的。他们有一个健身房。
They had a cafeteria. Wait. Wait, a cafeteria like with a train, you want down a lot, like a buffet? Yes. You would have loved it. Like a Vegas buffet. Like a Vegas buffet. I love a buffet.
他们有一个自助餐厅。等等。等等，一个自助餐厅，就像有火车的那种，你走进去，像自助餐一样？是的。你会喜欢的。就像拉斯维加斯的自助餐。就像拉斯维加斯的自助餐。我喜欢自助餐。
They're fancy. That's what I'm telling you. What was your character? I played this character, Stacy Wanamaker, and I was, I was a wedding planner and I was there to plan the wedding of Wilma Valdirama and Mila Kunis. They came and consulted me and I only worked with the two of them. All of my scenes were just with the two of them. Here's the thing.
它们很高级。这就是我要告诉你的。你的角色是什么？我扮演这个角色，斯黛西·沃纳梅克，我是一个婚礼策划师，我去那里是为了策划威尔默·瓦尔德拉玛和米拉·库尼斯婚礼。他们来找我咨询，我只和他们两个一起工作。我所有的场景都只有他们两个。事情是这样的。
That entire cast was so famous. Ashton Kutcher. Yeah. He was married to Demi Moore at the time. Oh. Yeah. Wilma Valdirama was dating Lindsay Lohan at the time. Airman.
整个演员阵容都太出名了。阿什顿·库彻。是的。他当时和黛米·摩尔结婚。哦。是的。威尔默·瓦尔德拉玛当时在和林赛·罗韩约会。埃尔曼。
Right? Tofer Grace. All these guys are there and they're all talking about their very famous lives. And I'm just listening to stories about Lindsay Lohan. They're talking about it like. It's their life. It's their life. And I wanted to be like, you guys, I'm just like a regular person and I'm hearing a lot
对吧？托弗·格雷斯。所有这些人都在那里，他们都在谈论他们非常著名的生活。而我只是在听关于林赛·罗韩的故事。他们谈论它就像。那是他们的生活。那是他们的生活。我想说，你们好，我只是一个普通人，我听到了很多
of dish. But I have never repeated what I heard because I believe that there is a code of silence when you're on a set. This is true because I'm looking at her right now like, what the heck lady you've held out on me. I know. I don't repeat what I hear on sets. I believe it's actually.
八卦。但我从来没有重复过我听到的事情，因为我相信在片场有一个沉默法条。这是真的，因为我现在看着她，就像，搞什么鬼，女士，你对我有所隐瞒。我知道。我不会重复我在片场听到的事情。我认为这实际上是。
Not even to your BFF. Not even to my BFF. You know what? I'm applauding you. Hey. Thank you. I don't know that I can say the same. Oh.
甚至不对你的死党说。甚至不对我的死党说。你知道吗？我为你鼓掌。嘿。谢谢。我不知道我能不能说同样的话。哦。
I think I would tell you. I would tell you. Well. You're the vault if someone tells you something. Just if I overhear stuff like that, I just think that's an actor space. Those people should be able to come to work and talk about their lives and not worry about being in the tabloids. I just think that's important.
我想我会告诉你。我会告诉你。好吧。如果有人告诉你什么，你就是保险箱。只是如果我偶然听到这样的话，我只认为那是演员的空间。那些人应该能够来工作并谈论他们的生活，而不必担心上小报。我只是觉得这很重要。
I think that's important too. But I think you could tell your best friend. Okay. Maybe so. I wouldn't call a tabloid, but I'd maybe say to you, okay, so guess what? Lindsay Lohan. Haha. Well.
我也觉得这很重要。但我觉得你可以告诉你的最好朋友。好吧。也许吧。我不会打电话给小报，但我可能会对你说，好吧，所以你猜怎么着？林赛·罗韩。哈哈。好吧。
But you know what? Bless her heart. Okay. But I'll also say these guys were huge stars and they were so nice. At the end of their taping, they went out into the audience for probably almost an hour and signed autographs like they had been on the air for something like seven years at this point. Nice.
但你知道吗？愿上帝保佑她。好吧。但我还要说，这些家伙都是大明星，他们人很好。在他们拍摄结束时，他们走进观众席，大概将近一个小时都在签名，就像他们当时已经播出大约七年了一样。不错。
That's classy. Yeah. And I just thought, I thought they were really classy group. I actually met Wilmer a while back. I do a charity in Kansas for Children's Mercy Hospital. I love it so much. And really the people that started it are Eric Stone Street and Jason Sudeikis, Paul Rudd, Rob Riggle, who was on an episode of The Office later on Boo's Cruise and Dave
这很有品位。是的。而且我只是觉得，我觉得他们是一个非常有品位的群体。我前不久其实见到了威尔默。我在堪萨斯州的一家儿童慈悲医院做慈善。我太喜欢它了。真正创办它的人是埃里克·斯通斯特里特和杰森·苏戴奇斯、保罗·路德、罗布·里格尔，他后来客串过《办公室》的“乘船狂欢”，还有戴夫
Keckner. They're all local Kansas City boys and they support Children's Mercy Hospital, which is amazing because Children's Mercy Hospital takes all kids. You don't have to have insurance. They take you no matter what. That's amazing. It's amazing. They do a few celebrity things to raise money and they had a celebrity woofle ball game.
凯克纳。他们都是堪萨斯城的本地男孩，他们支持儿童慈悲医院，这太棒了，因为儿童慈悲医院接收所有的孩子。你不需要有保险。无论如何他们都接收你。这太棒了。这太棒了。他们做一些名人活动来筹集资金，他们有一场名人威浮球比赛。
Is it woofle ball? It's woofle ball. It's woofle like a dog thing. It's a woofle ball. Is it woofle ball? Woofle ball. Oh God. I've been calling it woofle ball for a long time.
是威浮球吗？是威浮球。它像狗的东西一样叫威浮。这是一个威浮球。是威浮球吗？威浮球。哦，天哪。我叫它威浮球很久了。
Oh, Ange. Maybe that's why. People don't know what I'm talking about. I said woofle. It's not woofle ball. It's spelled with an I. W-I-F-F-L-E. How often are you writing woofle? Woofle ball.
哦，安吉。也许这就是为什么。人们不知道我在说什么。我说的是威浮。这不是威浮球。它是用字母i拼写的。W-I-F-F-L-E。你多久写一次威浮？威浮球。
Woofle ball. Oh, good God. Okay. So we're playing woofle ball in Kansas City to raise money for Children's Mercy Hospital. And I was on Rob Riggles' team and he was like, Kinsey, you cannot strike out. Jason Sudeikis is pitching. He's going to throw a lot of wacky stuff at you because it's a woofle ball. And he was like, you can't strike out.
威浮球。哦，天哪。好吧。所以我们在堪萨斯城打威浮球，为儿童慈悲医院筹集资金。我在罗布·里格尔的团队里，他说，金西，你绝对不能三振出局。杰森·苏戴奇斯是投球手。他会向你投很多古怪的球，因为这是一个威浮球。他说，你不能三振出局。
I was like, okay, Riggle. There was like a whole stadium full of people. Like we played on the practice field for the Kansas City Royals. Yeah, you're right. I've seen it. It's amazing. It's a bunch of people. And so Wilmer had a bat before me.
我说，好吧，里格尔。现场有一个体育场满是人。就像我们在堪萨斯城皇家队的训练场上比赛一样。是的，你是对的。我见过。这太棒了。有一大群人。所以威尔默在我之前上场击球。
Okay. And he swung as hard as he could at that woofle ball. And? And he struck out. It was like air. And I was like, oh no. But then I thought, I can't do worse than that. So I was up next to bat and I hit it to third and I got on first and I was really happy.
好吧。他用尽全力挥棒打那个威浮球。然后呢？然后他三振出局了。就像打在空气上一样。然后我想，哦，不。但随后我想，我不能比那更糟糕了。所以我是下一个上场击球的，我把它打到了三垒，我上了的一垒，我真的很高兴。
And Riggle was like, yes, Kinsey. But Wilmer was really nice. This is my point. Your Wilmer Valderrama story is that he struck out a horrible woofle ball player. He's not horrible. And you outshined him. I just want to break down. That's a summary of what you just said.
里格尔说，太棒了，金西。但威尔默人真的很好。这就是我的重点。你的威尔默·瓦尔德拉玛的故事是，他三振了一个糟糕的威浮球球员。他并不糟糕。而你大放异彩。我只想总结一下。那是你刚才所说的话的总结。
Well, basically, I'm pretty sure Jason Sudeikis did not throw him a very nice pitch. Well, now you're just throwing Jason Sudeikis under the bus. No, I'm not. Wait, I am giving him a compliment. He clearly was throwing some zingers. And that is why Wilmer couldn't hit the woofle ball. Yes, Jenna. Okay.
嗯，基本上，我很确定杰森·苏戴奇斯没有给他投一个很好的球。好吧，现在你只是把杰森·苏戴奇斯推到公交车底下。不，我没有。等等，我是在称赞他。他显然投了一些精彩的球。这就是为什么威尔默打不到威浮球。是的，珍娜。好吧。
Well, I do want to say in all seriousness, Angela, I really admire what you do with that charity every year. And I just think Children's Mercy Hospital is a really special place. Thanks so much, Jenna. It's really such a special event every year, and I'm so thankful that Rob Riggle and those guys invite me to participate because it's really meant a lot to me. Yeah. But maybe this coming year, you should call it by its proper name, woofle ball.
嗯，我确实想郑重地说，安吉拉，我真的很佩服你每年为那个慈善机构所做的事情。我只是觉得儿童慈悲医院是一个非常特殊的地方。非常感谢，珍娜。每年确实是一个非常特殊的活动，我非常感谢罗布·里格尔和那些家伙邀请我参加，因为这对我意义重大。是的。但也许在接下来的这一年里，你应该用它的本名来称呼它，威浮球。
You know what? I'm going to make a shirt that says, I'm here to play woofle ball. Okay. Where are we? We are on Fast Fact Number Three. Okay. I'm moving us along. Please.
你知道吗？我要做一件衬衫，上面写着，我是来打威浮球的。好吧。我们在哪里？我们在冷知识之三。好吧。我把我们带回正题。拜托。
Fast Fact Number Three, when we shot this episode, it was mid-July 2005, and it was 100 degrees outside in the parking lot of that episode. So hot. Do you know my ears sunburned? No. Yes. My little ears sunburned. I had this French braid, right?
冷知识之三，当我们拍摄这一集时，那是2005年7月中旬，那集的停车场外面有100度。太热了。你知道我的耳朵晒伤了吗？没有。是的。我的小耳朵晒伤了。我梳了这个法式辫子，对吧？
So my ears were fully exposed, and we didn't put sunscreen on them. And there are a few time codes I could give you where you see my ears look like these little pink elf ears. We also are dressed like it is cold out because this aired in fall in Scranton, but we shot it in the dead of summer in Los Angeles. Oh, yeah. It was triple digits. Yeah, it was crazy.
所以我的耳朵完全露出来了，我们没有在上面涂防晒霜。有几个时间码我可以给你看，你可以看到我的耳朵看起来像这些粉红的小精灵耳朵。我们还穿着好像外面很冷一样的衣服，因为这在斯克兰顿的秋天播出，但我们在盛夏的洛杉矶拍摄的。哦，是的。气温达到三位数了。是的，太疯狂了。
So before we go to break, I just wanted to take a moment and say something kind of serious. I want to dedicate this episode to one of our young fans who passed away recently. Her name was Lauren. She was 10 years old, and I was speaking with her mother. The office was a really big source of comfort to their family and continues to be a source of comfort to their family. And that's something that's really meaningful to Angela and I, and it's not lost on us that this is the case for a lot of people.
所以在我们休息之前，我只是想花点时间说一些有点严肃的事情。我想把这一集献给最近去世的一位年轻粉丝。她叫劳伦。她10岁了，我当时正在和她的母亲谈话。办公室是他们家庭的一个非常大的安慰来源，并且继续成为他们家庭的安慰来源。这对安吉拉和我来说意义重大，我们并没有忘记这对很多人来说也是如此。
And so I just wanted to share with you that Lauren's favorite episodes were lecture circuit because of Kelly's birthday, and she also loved Michael's birthday. Well, you know, Jenna shared with me a little bit of Lauren's mom's story, and I was crying as I listened to the message you left as a mom, and I know it really impacted you as well. And we do meet people throughout the course of just living our lives here that share with us what the office has meant to them and what it's gotten them through. And you guys, it is with our whole hearts that we tell you that means a lot to us.
所以我只想与你们分享，劳伦最喜欢的剧集是《巡回讲座》，因为凯莉的生日，她也非常喜欢迈克尔的生日。嗯，你知道，珍娜跟我分享了一点劳伦妈妈的故事，当我听你作为一个妈妈留下的信息时，我在哭，我知道这对你也有很大的影响。我们在生活的过程中确实会遇到一些人，他们与我们分享《办公室》对他们的意义以及它如何帮助他们度过难关。伙计们，我们全心全意地告诉你们，这对我们意义重大。
Yeah. We're honored to be part of something that brings comfort to people in times of need. We really are. So thank you so much, everybody, for watching the show and for listening to us, and we'll be back after this break. All right, Jenna, I think you forgot something. I forgot the summary. Yeah, I think you need to tell us the summary.
是的。我们很荣幸能成为在人们需要时带来安慰的事物的一部分。我们真的是这样。所以非常感谢大家观看节目并倾听我们的心声，休息后我们将回归。好吧，珍娜，我想你忘了一些东西。我忘了总结。是的，我想你需要告诉我们总结。
All right. Here's a summary of the fire. Ryan in the office has to evacuate after the fire alarm suddenly goes off. And while in the parking lot, the employees play games like Desert Island and Who Would You Do, Michael learns that Ryan the temp wants to run his own business, and he starts to mentor him until he learns that Ryan is going to business school and knows more than he does. The attention that Michael is paying to Ryan makes Dwight very jealous, and we all want
好的。这里是《大火》的总结。办公室里的瑞安在火灾警报突然响起后必须疏散。当在停车场时，员工玩诸如荒岛和你想和谁做之类的小游戏，迈克尔得知实习生瑞安想经营自己的生意，他开始指导他，直到他得知瑞安要去商学院并且懂得比他多。迈克尔对瑞安的关注让德怀特非常嫉妒，我们都想
to know, how did the fire start? Yeah. Who started the fire? We started the fire. The episode begins with a famous Pam line. Dunder Mifflin. This is Pam. Oh, yes.
知道，火灾是怎么开始的？是的。谁放的火？我们放的火。这一集以一句著名的帕姆台词开场。邓德米夫林。我是帕姆。哦，是的。
Who's calling? Who's calling, everybody? It's Katie. Oh, yeah. Calling Jim. Pam has to transfer Katie. Uh-huh. So, Jenna, I have written here, what does that say?
谁打来的？谁打来的，各位？是凯蒂。哦，是的。打给吉姆。帕姆必须转接凯蒂。嗯哼。所以，珍娜，我在这里写了，那上面写的是什么？
Pam sass. There is some serious Pam sass in this episode, and it comes right out of the gate when you say, you can just give her your extension. Yeah. Oh, so much sass. You are ticked off that Katie is calling. I mean, just give her your direct line. Why do I have to answer the phone?
帕姆的辣。这一集里帕姆有一些严重的辣味，当你开口说“你可以直接把你的分机号给她”时，它就直接显露出来了。是的。哦，太辣了。你对凯蒂打电话感到很生气。我的意思是，直接给你的直线电话不就行了。为什么我要接电话？
Yeah. Why do I have to take your messages? I have to deal with that. I'm not your secretary. Wait, I know this is like backing us up a little bit, but right at 14 seconds, there is something that brought such a big smile to my face. There is a yellow duck stuffed animal laying under Jim's computer screen. Quack, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack.
是的。为什么我要接你的留言？我得处理那个。我又不是你的秘书。等等，我知道这有点让我们倒退了一小步，但在14秒左右，有什么东西让我的脸上露出了灿烂的微笑。吉姆的电脑屏幕下放着一个黄色的鸭子毛绒玩具。呱，呱，呱，呱，呱，呱。
And you guys, and seasons later, you know, my daughter was born season five, and she would come to the set all the time, and she would come on set to my desk area. She was obsessed with that little yellow duck, and she would grab it and squeeze it, and it'd be like, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack. And then they got a monkey she would squeeze, that would be like, whee, whee, whee. I'm sure it drove everyone crazy, but she would go around set, little tiny Isabel looking for the duck and the monkey. I'll never forget that.
伙计们，几年后，你知道的，我的女儿在第五季出生了，她总是来片场，她会来到片场的我的办公桌区域。她迷上了那只黄色的小鸭子，她会抓住它并捏它，它就会发出，呱，呱，呱，呱，呱，呱，呱，呱，呱。然后他们弄到了一只她会捏的猴子，它会发出，吱，吱，吱。我确信这把每个人都逼疯了，但她会在片场四处走动，小小的伊莎贝尔寻找着鸭子和猴子。我永远不会忘记这一点。
I'll never forget that. I have pictures of her holding that duck on set. Okay. So, okay, back to the PAMSAS. She's ticked off at Katie, and here we go. The next scene is Michael and Ryan in Michael's office. Michael has to do Ryan's evaluation, which turns in to Michael teaching him about business. He has 10 things he's going to tell him, but he can only think of one, and he's going to
我永远不会忘记这一点。我有她拿着那个鸭子在片场的照片。好吧。所以，好吧，回到帕姆的辣。她生凯蒂的气，我们走吧。下一个场景是迈克尔和瑞安在迈克尔的办公室里。迈克尔必须对瑞安进行评估，这变成了迈克尔教他商业知识。他有10件事要告诉他，但他只能想出一件，他会
get back to him. He's going to tell him the rest later in the day. I have a little screen grab moment, guys. At three minutes, six seconds, we've talked about this before. I have that there is a green magic eight ball on his desk. There's a great shot of it on Michael's desk. It's got a dollar sign on it. It's not actually the number eight.
回过头来找他。他要在当天晚些时候把剩下的告诉他。伙计们，我有一个截图时刻。在三分钟六秒时，我们以前讨论过这个。我那里有一个绿色的8号魔术球在桌上。迈克尔的桌子上有它的一个很好的特写镜头。上面有一个美元符号。其实不是数字8。
It's a dollar sign. Oh, this must be some sort of other product, not a magic eight ball, like a special like money magic eight ball. Yeah. Yeah. And I like looked online for it last night. You could find it? I could not find it.
是一个美元符号。哦，这一定是什么其他产品，不是8号魔术球，就像一个特殊的金钱8号魔术球。是的。是的。我昨晚在网上查了。你能找到吗？我找不到。
I just grabbed my phone to Google it. I know. I looked up, you know, but yes, he's got a green magic eight ball that's got the dollar sign on it. So if anyone knows anything about that, I want you to email me. Yeah. Please. Office ladies at earwolf.com.
我刚拿起手机去谷歌一下。我知道。我查了，你知道的，但是是的，他有一个绿色的8号魔术球，上面有美元符号。所以如果有人知道这方面的事情，我希望你发邮件给我。是的。拜托。officeladies@earwolf.com。
Yeah. So if you have a green magic eight ball with a dollar sign on it, I want to know. Angela wants to know, please. And I want to know what it says when you shake it and look at it. That's what she said. That's what she said. I know. Listen, I thought, I thought your first line out of the gate, you can just give her your
是的。所以如果你有一个带有美元符号的绿色8号魔术球，我想知道。安吉拉想知道，拜托。而且我想知道当你摇晃它并看着它时它上面写着什么。这就是她说的。这就是她说的。我知道。听着，我觉得，我觉得你开场的第一句，你可以直接把你的分机号给她。
extension. That's what she said. That's a little bit. All right. All right. Next up. The fire alarm goes off. Yes.
这就是她说的。那是一点点。好吧。好吧。接下来。火灾警报响了。是的。
Both Dwight and Angela start yelling and instructing people Dwight, everything. He grabs the water bottle. He punches the extinguisher. He grabs Kelly. How did Mindy get through that? I don't know. But she has a bun. Still.
德怀特和安吉拉都开始大喊并指示人们，德怀特，一切。他抓起水瓶。他一拳打向灭火器。他抓住了凯莉。曼迪是怎么挺过去的？我不知道。但她有一个发髻。依然。
Still. When will her hair come down? When will she not have a bun? Angela, what was that scene like when you were shooting that? It was so much fun. How much of that was improv? I mean, that scene was scripted and there were beats we had to hit to get everyone out of the room and people were reacting off of our cues.
依然。她的头发什么时候会散下来？她什么时候不会梳发髻？安吉拉，当你拍摄那个场景时，那个场景是怎样的？太有趣了。其中有多少是即兴发挥？我的意思是，那个场景是有剧本的，我们需要达到一些节拍才能让每个人都离开房间，人们根据我们的提示做出反应。
My lines were scripted. I think a lot of some of like rain stuff was improvised because I have lines clearly my character has taken some class and being the safety officer because my lines are do not panic, arms at your side, find your safety partner and his are like, uh, no, panicking is warranted. You should be panicking. How excited was your character when the fire alarm went off? Like your character is one of those people who's so prepared.
我的台词是有剧本的。我认为雷恩的一些东西是即兴发挥的，因为我有台词，显然我的角色上过一些课并担任安全官，因为我的台词是不要惊慌，手臂放在身体两侧，找到你的安全搭档，而他的台词是，呃，不，恐慌是有道理的。你应该恐慌。当火灾警报响起时，你的角色有多兴奋？就像你的角色是那种准备非常充分的人。
Who were the two most excited people? When the fire alarm went off. Dwight and Angela. So when we get down into the parking lot, I noticed something. This is another episode where Jim takes charge just like office Olympics. He's the fun guy. He's the guy who's going to keep everything going. And I thought it was interesting that in real life, John was kind of that guy on our set.
哪两个人最兴奋？当火灾警报响起时。德怀特和安吉拉。所以当我们下到停车场时，我注意到了某些东西。这是另一集，吉姆像奥运办公室一样承担起责任。他是那个有趣的人。他是那个让一切继续下去的人。我发现有趣的是，在现实生活中，约翰在我们的片场有点像那样。
Who did that? He would. We were like stuck somewhere on location or in the conference room, definitely in the conference room. Whenever we had conference room scenes and it was our five and we were in a slump, John would rally us. John would. He would like do bits and like he really, he would get us laughing and yeah.
谁做过那个？他会。我们被困在某个外景地或会议室里，绝对是在会议室里。每当我们在会议室里有场景，那是我们的五个人，我们处于低谷时，约翰会振作我们。约翰会。他会做一些段子，而且他真的，他会让我们笑，是的。
So I thought that was a way that he is sort of like his character. Yes. A little bit. Yeah. Okay. I have some time codes really quickly. Go for it. First of all, we skip past this, but at three minutes, 34 seconds, Meredith has pink workout
所以我认为这是他有点像他的角色的方式。是的。有点。是的。好的。我很快有一些时间码。去吧。首先，我们跳过了这个，但在三分34秒时，梅雷迪思的桌上有粉红色的健身
weights on her desk. What is Meredith doing? Like arm lifts over there? What's she doing? Oh my gosh. I don't know. Also, there's a bright red book that looks like a Bible. I'm positive it's not.
哑铃。梅雷迪思在干什么？在那做手臂举重吗？她在干什么？哦，天哪。我不知道。此外，还有一本看起来像圣经的亮红色书。我敢肯定它不是。
It's probably some kind of fake accounting book, but it looks like a Bible. And then at five minutes, 20 seconds, I have to bring this up. We all walk out of the building, right? I was wearing my own giant chunky loafers that I had bought at Payless for the pilot. So for the first like two seasons, I had two pairs of shoes basically. I had my chunky Payless loafers and my sass shoes. How did you decide which ones to wear each day? Did you get to pick or did they pick for you?
它可能是一种假会计书，但它看起来像圣经。然后在五分20秒时，我必须提出这一点。我们都走出了大楼，对吧？我穿着我自己的巨大厚底乐福鞋，那是我在试播集时在佩勒斯买的。所以在前两季左右，我基本上有两双鞋。我有我厚底的佩勒斯乐福鞋和我的辣妹鞋。你是怎么决定每天穿哪一双的？你可以挑选还是他们为你挑选？
They would set them out, I think. Okay. But knowing me, I just wore whatever I wanted. Yeah. So we've been over that. I did get fancier shoes season three, everybody. This is very important, Jenna. Go.
我想他们会把它们摆出来。好吧。但了解我，我只是穿我想穿的任何东西。是的。所以我们讨论过这个。第三季我穿了更高级的鞋，大家。这非常重要，珍娜。去吧。
This is the episode of the crappy phone. Oh. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. First of all, two people walk out of the building on their phones. Do you know who they are? Who? And Devin, both are on calls.
这是那部烂手机的一集。哦。哦，是的。哦，是的。首先，两个人拿着手机走出大楼。你知道他们是谁吗？谁？和德文，两人都在打电话。
Oscar's on a call the whole time like Dwight and Angela are herding everyone out. He stays on the phone outside and it looks like a really old flip phone. This is when the show is really dated is if you look at these phones. Same with Devin. Devin has on like these slick sunglasses. Oh yeah. He's like, oh yeah. Those real skinny sunglasses.
奥斯卡一直在打电话，就像德怀特和安吉拉把每个人赶出去一样。他在外面一直打电话，看起来像一个非常旧的翻盖手机。这就是这部剧真正过时的地方，如果你看这些手机。德文也是如此。德文戴着这种圆滑的太阳镜。哦，是的。他就像，哦，是的。那些非常细的太阳镜。
He was so smart. I would have loved some sunglasses and he has a cell phone. And then in the later part of the episode, which I'll wait for two more cell phones make an appearance by two other castmates and they are both equally really old. I feel like something that really dated the show as well are some of the Desert Island movies. Okay. Desert Island movies was a big thing that came up.
他太聪明了。我本来希望有一些太阳镜，而且他有一部手机。然后在这一集的后半部分，我将等待另外两个演员拿出另外两部手机，它们同样都非常老。我觉得让这部剧过时的还有一些荒岛电影。好的。荒岛电影是一个很大的事情。
Should we talk about them? We should. But you know, I have this card, but now I feel really stupid reading it, you know, because of my waffle ball moment. You've been, you've changed it again. You were calling it Waffle Ball like a dog. It's Waffle Ball. Waffle.
我们应该谈谈它们吗？我们应该。但你知道，我有这 张卡，但现在我觉得读它真的很蠢，你知道的，因为我的华夫球时刻。你又改了。你一直把它叫作像狗一样的华夫球。它是威浮球。华夫。
Okay. You just called it Waffle. Well, because I was trying to get it right and I got it wrong again. I went from Waffle Ball. Also, I'm Southern, so I think I just said Waffle Ball. You want to play Waffle Ball? I've sort of made an as of myself with the whole Waffle Ball moment, so this is not going to help.
好吧。你刚刚叫它华夫。嗯，因为我在努力把它说对，结果我又弄错了。我从威浮球。而且，我是南方人，所以我想我刚才只是说了华夫球。你想打华夫球吗？我因为整个华夫球时刻而有点让自己出丑了，所以这没有帮助。
What if I have this written on a note card ready? All right. You have it written on a photo card. Yeah. Because I ran out of note cards. Desert Island. WTF. What does that mean?
如果我把这个写在一张准备好的记事卡上呢？好吧。你把它写在一张相纸上了。是的。因为我用完了记事卡。荒岛。操他妈的。那是什么意思？
It's 640. John, as Jim says, Desert Island. It's Deserted Island. What would you take on a Deserted Island? It's Deserted Island. Come on, Sam in the booth. It's Deserted Island. What would you take on a Deserted Island?
是640。吉姆说，荒岛。那是荒废的岛。你在荒岛上会带什么？那是荒废的岛。拜托，展台里的萨姆。那是荒废的岛。你在荒岛上会带什么？
Are you nodding? Yeah. Desert Island. That didn't make sense to me. It's a Deserted Island. You're so right. Thank you. A Desert Island.
你在点头吗？是的。荒岛。这对我来说没有意义。这是一个荒废的岛。就像荒岛余生。对的。你太对了，安吉拉。谢谢。一个荒岛。
Oh my God. Am I redeemed for Waffle Ball? Is it Desert or Deserted Island? Why? It's Deserted. Yes. Thank you. So he's like, okay, Desert Island.
哦，天哪。我为华夫球赎罪了吗？是荒岛还是荒废的岛？为什么？是荒废的。是的。谢谢。所以他说，好吧，荒岛。
I'm like, well, why do I want to go to some arid Desert Island with other people? No. It's a Deserted Island. Like castaway. Right. You're so right, Angela. Thank you. I have a fan question about, should we call it Desert Island or Deserted Island?
我说，好吧，我为什么要去一些干旱的荒岛和其他人在一起？不。这是一个荒废的岛。就像鲁滨逊漂流记。对的。你太对了，安吉拉。谢谢。我有一个关于这个的粉丝问题，我们应该叫它荒岛还是荒废的岛？
I don't even know now. Hayden asked, did any of Pam's Desert Island movies match your personal favorite movies? Pam's movies were Fargo, Edward Scissorhands, Dazed and Confused, Breakfast Club, and Princess Bride. And then you had your ultimate all-time favorite that you never got to say. That Jim wouldn't let me say. And a ton of people wrote in and said, what is Pam's favorite movie? I don't know.
我现在都不知道了。海登问，帕姆的荒岛电影里有任何一部符合你的个人最爱电影吗？帕姆的电影是《冰血暴》、《剪刀手爱德华》、《年少轻狂》、《早餐俱乐部》和《公主新娘》。然后你有你从未能说出口的终极最爱。吉姆不让我说的那部。一大群人写信来问，帕姆最喜欢什么电影？我不知道。
It wasn't in the script. And I texted BJ and I said, did you ever intend, did you have a favorite movie? And he said, no. It was never written. We'll never know. Right. I'm so sorry. I even said to BJ, do you want to just make one up now, just like, give us an answer?
它不在剧本里。我给B·J发短信说，你曾经有意过吗，你有一部最喜欢的电影吗？他说，没有。从来没有写过。我们永远不会知道。对的。我很抱歉。我甚至对B·J说，你现在想随便编一个吗，就像，给我们一个答案？
And he felt that for the integrity of the show, he could not do that. BJ is so honorable. I know. So we will never know her favorite movie. And then as for me, okay, I do like Fargo, but who wants to watch that over and over again on an island? I don't want to see that leg go into the wood chipper over and over again. Over and over again.
他觉得为了节目的完整性，他不能那样做。B·J太高尚了。我知道。所以我们永远不会知道她最喜欢的电影。然后至于我，好吧，我确实喜欢《冰血暴》，但谁想在一个岛上一遍又一遍地看那个？我不想看到那条腿一遍又一遍地卷入碎木机里。一遍又一遍。
To me, when I'm thinking about what movies do I take on an island, I'm thinking what can I stand to watch repeatedly? Yes. And I love Fargo, but I don't know that I could watch it over and over and over. Yes. And I would say maybe Princess Bride. I've seen that over and over and over again. I do love Princess Bride.
对我来说，当我在考虑我在岛上带什么电影时，我在想什么是我能忍受反复观看的？是的。我喜欢《冰血暴》，但我不知道我能不能一遍又一遍地看它。是的。我会说也许是《公主新娘》。我一遍又一遍地看过那个。我确实喜欢《公主新娘》。
And that holds up. But still, my list would be different. What, do you have your list? I did. I made my list. I have my list too. Let me futz through my paperwork, Jenna. All right.
而且经得起考验。但即便如此，我的名单还是会不同。什么，你有你的名单吗？我有。我列了我的名单。我也有我的名单。让我翻翻我的文件，珍娜。好吧。
Okay. This one, okay. Anyway, you go. Okay. My list would be The Edge. Do you know that movie? No. It's a movie by Hopkins and Alec Baldwin.
好吧。这个，好吧。总之，你去吧。好的。我的名单会是《势不两立》。你知道那部电影吗？不。那是霍普金斯和亚历克·鲍德温主演的一部电影。
It's a survival. Is this the one with the bear? Yes. Oh, God. It's a survival movie. I watch it every year. It's so good. What?
这是一个关于生存的。这是有熊的那部吗？是的。哦，天哪。这是一部生存电影。我每年都看。太棒了。什么？
It's written by David Mamet. It has one of my favorite lines, what one man has done, another can do. That gets me through tough times. Okay. I think to myself, well, someone else has probably done it. I can do it too. I love that that message gets to you. I cannot believe in all the years we've been friends.
这是大卫·马梅特编剧的。它有我最喜欢的一句台词，一人能做之事，他人亦能。这帮我度过了艰难的时期。好吧。我想，嗯，别人可能已经做到了。我也能做到。我喜欢那个信息能触动你。我真不敢相信我们做朋友这么多年了。
I did not know that you watch The Edge every year as like some motivational thing. I also didn't know you had gossip from, you know, that 70s show, so I don't know what's happening. Oh, my gosh. There's a lot of things you don't know about me, Angela. I guess so. You're a mystery. All right.
我竟然不知道你每年都把《势不两立》作为某种励志的东西来看。我也不知道你有来自，你知道的，那七十年代秀的八卦，所以我不知道发生了什么。哦，天哪。关于我，有很多你不知道的事情，安吉拉。我想是的。你是个谜。好吧。
I also felt like if I brought The Edge, there might be some like survival techniques that I could learn while on the island. This is very you. That could help me get off. That is very you. So I just thought it would be instructional entertaining. Okay. All right.
我也觉得如果我带了《势不两立》，我可能会在岛上学到一些生存技巧。这非常符合你的风格。那能帮我离开。这非常符合你的风格。所以我只是觉得它既有教育意义又有趣。好吧。好吧。
That is Dwight. Are you Dwight? A little bit. Okay. Then I would also bring the three amigos. Oh, that's a great one. I love that. Oh, I love Tootsie.
那是德怀特。你是德怀特吗？有点。好吧。然后我还会带《三个福克斯》。哦，那是个极好的。我喜欢那个。哦，我喜欢《窈窕淑男》。
Terms of Endearment. Oh, I love Terms of Endearment, which was written by Larry McMurtry, who's from my hometown of Archer City, Texas. It's so good. All the performances in that. Deborah Winger made me want to be an actress. I love that movie. Okay.
《母女情深》。哦，我喜欢《母女情深》，那是拉里·麦克默特里写的，他来自我的家乡得克萨斯州阿彻城。太棒了。里面的所有表演。黛博拉·温格让我渴望成为一名演员。我喜欢那部电影。好吧。
And then my final movie that I'm going to say, I'm a little on the fence about, but I'm going to say it. Okay. Parasite. What? The Korean film. Here's the thing. I just saw it and I really want to see it again.
然后我要说的最后一部电影，我有点犹豫，但我还是要说。好的。《寄生虫》。什么？那部韩国电影。事情是这样的。我刚看过它，我真的很想再看一遍。
So I mean, I just loved it. I thought it was beautiful and amazing and just so good. Okay. I need to see it. Those are my movies. I need to see it. I haven't seen it. I don't know why I cited it, except that it sounds stressful to me and you already have
所以我的意思是，我太喜欢它了。我觉得它美丽、惊艳而且太棒了。好吧。我得去看看。那是我的电影。我得去看看。我没看过。我不知道我为什么要引用它，除了它听起来让我感到压力，而且你的名单上已经有了
the edge on your list, which also sounds stressful. But I've got comedies. Okay. I've got a good cry with Terms of Endearment. And I've got some survival. Then three amigos. Okay. Jenna asked me if I would make my list and I want you guys all to know the minute I read
《势不两立》，那听起来也很有压力。但我有喜剧。好吧。我有《母女情深》里的一场痛哭。我有一些生存电影。然后是《三个福克斯》。好吧。珍娜问我是否会列出我的名单，我希望你们所有人都知道，从她那里读到那个的一瞬间，她就给我发了短信。
that from her, she texted me. I did an enormous eye roll. I knew you'd be stressed. I don't like to make. I don't like lists. You don't like to categorize. I don't like lists. So I did it, but I didn't like doing it.
我翻了个巨大的白眼。我知道你会感到有压力。我不喜欢制作。我不喜欢列清单。我不喜欢列清单。所以我这样做了，但我并不喜欢这样做。
I love meet the parents. Yeah. It has an all-time great line too, Jenna, that gets me through things. What is it? I have nipples, Greg. Can you milk me? They're so similar. The things that get us through things are so incredibly similar.
我喜欢《拜见岳父大人》。是的。它也有一句历久弥新的伟大的台词，珍娜，它帮我度过了难关。是什么？我有乳头，格雷格。你能给我挤奶吗？它们太相似了。帮助我们度过难关的事情是如此难以置信地相似。
It's weird. I love Pride and Prejudice, the one with Keira Knightley. Okay. I love it. It's over and over. Yes. I've seen it so many times. I love it.
这很奇怪。我喜欢《傲慢与偏见》，凯拉·奈特莉主演的那部。好吧。我喜欢。它是一遍又一遍的。是的。我看过很多次了。我喜欢。
It's also beautiful. I love it. I love Out of Africa with Meryl Streep. And Robert Redford. Robert Redford. He's swoony. He's swoony. But I grew up overseas and when I came stateside, I said goodbye to people that I'd never see
它也很美。我喜欢。我喜欢梅丽尔·斯特里普主演的《走出非洲》。还有罗伯特·雷德福。罗伯特·雷德福。他让人神魂颠倒。他让人神魂颠倒。但我是在海外长大的，当我回到美国时，我和再也见不到的人告别了。
again. And I watched this movie as a kid and when she had to say goodbye to everyone in Africa, like I was bawling. I love the matrix. Oh, that's a good one. There is no spoon. That gets me through too, Jenna. I don't know, guys.
我小时候看过这部电影，当她在非洲不得不和所有人告别时，我哭得稀里哗啦。我喜欢《黑客帝国》。哦，那是个不错的选择。没有汤匙。这也帮我度过了难关，珍娜。我不知道，伙计们。
I love The Empire Strikes Back. And then like a wild card. I love Shakespeare and Love. I also loved Elizabeth I with Kate Blanchette. I mean, I did write a term paper on Anne Boleyn, so I kind of love anything to do with like that time period, the age of, you know, the golden age. I did not know that about you. Yes.
我喜欢《帝国反击战》。然后像一张外卡。我喜欢《莎翁情史》。我也喜欢凯特·布兰切特主演的《伊丽莎白一世》。我的意思是，我确实写过一篇关于安妮·博林的学期论文，所以我有点喜欢任何与那个时期有关的东西，那个时代，你知道的，黄金时代。我不知道你还有这一面。是的。
I mean, I knew that you watched Pride and Prejudice a lot and I remember it because you texted me the first time you showed it to Isabel. Oh, yeah. Yeah. You know, I remember that was a big moment, but I did not know that you had such. Do you watch The Crown? Jenna, how do you not know this about me? You clearly never watch my Insta stories.
我的意思是，我知道你看了很多《傲慢与偏见》，我记得是因为你第一次给伊莎贝尔看时给我发了短信。哦，是的。是的。你知道，我记得那是一个重要的时刻，但我不知道你有这样的。你看《王冠》吗？珍娜，你怎么会对我一无所知？你显然从不看我的快拍。
Oh, no. Yes, I watch The Crown. I can't believe it's taking so long for it to come back and I can't wait. And it's finally here. Olivia Coleman. Also, I almost put on here none of these movies just Downton Abbey because I watched Downton Abbey. I'm already like going, I've made it through twice.
哦，不。是的，我看《王冠》。我真不敢相信它回来花了这么长时间，我等不及了。它终于来了。奥利维亚·科尔曼。还有，我差点把这些电影全删了，只留《唐顿庄园》，因为我看过《唐顿庄园》。我已经像这样，我已经看了两遍了。
I have another fan question. Okay. This is from Michael. Our episodes like this one where a good portion of the story is outdoors, a pain to shoot because of the need for daylight. Does it make for longer shoots? No. I thought the heat, the heat made it really hard because I felt really bad for the guys.
我还有另一个粉丝问题。好的。这是迈尔斯的。像这一集这样大部分故事都在户外的剧集，因为需要日光而很难拍摄吗？这会导致拍摄时间更长吗？没有。我觉得热，热让它变得真的很艰难，因为我真的很为那些男士感到难过。
They were in wool blazers and pants. They were so hot. And by the way, we're complaining, but we had camera operators who were on their feet all day with a giant camera on their shoulder. And then boom operators who were out in the hot sun holding a bum above their head. It was a hot day to work outside. It was. And my legs and hips were really sore after standing on that concrete for two days.
他们穿着羊毛西装外套和裤子。他们太热了。顺便说一句，我们在抱怨，但我们有摄像机操作员，他们整天扛着一个巨大的摄像机站着。然后还有吊杆操作员，他们在炎热的太阳下把吊杆举在头顶。那是一个在户外工作的好热的一天。是的。在那个混凝土上站了两天后，我的腿和臀部真的很酸痛。
I'll never forget that. Says the 75 year old. That's right. I needed some of those sass shoes. Oh yeah. So we talked about the movies that we would all take to the deserted island. Yes. And Angela, then there's that part with the books and I love your line.
我永远不会忘记那个。75 岁的老人说。没错。我需要那些时髦鞋子。哦，是的。所以我们讨论了我们都会带到荒岛上的电影。是的。然后，安吉拉，书的那部分，我很喜欢你的台词。
The Bible. The Bible. A purpose driven life. And then say, what's your third book? Say it to me. What's your third book? No. But then also, I love that you say you would take the Da Vinci code so you can burn the
《圣经》。《圣经》。《标杆人生》。然后说，你的第三本书是什么？对我说。你的第三本书是什么？不。但我也很喜欢你说你会带《达芬奇密码》，这样你就可以烧了
Da Vinci code. All right. What a great piece of dialogue. It's such a great piece of dialogue. And people ask me, what are lines that people quote back to you? Like you get Dunder Mifflin, this is Pam. I was at a concert for U2, a U2 concert. And there was a group of young guys in the section next to me and there was a whole banister
《达芬奇密码》。好吧。多么精彩的对白啊。这真的是一段很棒的对白。人们问我，有哪些台词是人们对你津津乐道的？就像你听到“邓德米夫林，这里是帕姆”。我在 U2 演唱会上，一场 U2 演唱会。我身旁的那一区有一群年轻小伙子，中间隔着一整道楼梯扶手
between us. Right? Yeah. And they leaned over this railing and they yelled, we take the Da Vinci code because we burn the Da Vinci code. Like that. And I was like, hey, fellas. So I actually get that line quoted to me.
对吧？是的。他们靠在这个栏杆上大喊，我们带《达芬奇密码》是因为我们烧了《达芬奇密码》。就像那样。然后我就想，嘿，伙计们。所以实际上真的有人对我引用这句台词。
I also love Stanley's face during Dwight's description of the book he would bring. Yeah. He would take the book, but then he would hollow out the book and put a bunch of stuff in it. A book that would actually be really helpful. Yeah. It's actually a good book to bring. He's going to hollow it out.
我也很喜欢在德怀特描述他要带的书时斯坦利的表情。是的。他会带这本书，但他会把书掏空，在里面塞满东西。一本实际上会非常实用的书。是的。这确实是一本适合带来的书。他要把它掏空。
Exactly. I have a question. Yeah. At six minutes, 54 seconds, all of these people are in the parking lot. There's a ton of people that you don't know and I have a theory about who I think they are. Who do you think they are? Well, I'm assuming there are other people who work in the building because Dunder Mifflin
没错。我有个问题。是的。在 6 分钟 54 秒时，所有这些人都在停车场。有很多你不认识的人，我对他们是谁有一个推测。你觉得他们是谁？嗯，我猜那是大楼里其他工作的人，因为邓德米夫林
isn't the only business. Right. I think they're advanced for refrigeration. Oh. That's what I thought they were. We know that business is there. I can't remember some of the other businesses that were in there. There's an episode later on where they have the meeting of the five.
不是唯一的企业。对吧。我觉得他们是先进冷冻设备的。哦。我就是这么想的。我们知道那个企业在那里。我记不清里面还有哪些其他企业了。后来有一集他们召集了五人会议。
The five. Oh yeah, the five business heads. Yes. But I can't remember what the other businesses are right now. I would need to prepare that. And I would when we discuss that episode. Oh. Well, is that SAS to me?
五人组。哦对，五大企业负责人。是的。但我现在记不清其他企业是什么了。我需要做点准备。等我们讨论那一集时我会准备的。哦。好吧，这是在对我耍态度吗？
No. When I brought something up that you're not prepared for? No. That wasn't SAS. That was just speaking. Why would I speak? Because you think it's SAS. I don't understand.
不。当我提起你没有准备好的事情时？不。那不是耍态度。那只是在说话。我为什么要说话？因为你觉得是在耍态度。我不明白。
I don't know. You guys listening, some of my favorite lines are when Jenna is just like being Jenna SAS instead of Pam SAS where she's like, I am giving you a compliment. Oh no. You need to know something. You can tell. You may speak. You may tell that story now.
我不知道。你们这些听众，我最喜欢的台词之一就是当詹娜只是表现得像詹娜式的傲娇，而不是帕姆式的傲娇，当时她说，我在给你赞美。哦，不。你需要知道一件事。你可以看出来。你可以说。你现在可以讲那个故事了。
After we record these podcasts, we edit these podcasts all together with our engineer Sam and our producer Cody. We sit in a room and we go over the podcast and we have to listen to ourselves back. And we have honed in on a few lines that now you give me trouble for. Apparently, in an episode, I say, I am giving you a compliment. And now the three of them tease me. We say it all the time. I am giving you a compliment.
在我们录完这些播客后，我们和我们的音频工程师萨姆以及我们的制片人科迪一起剪辑这些播客。我们坐在一个房间里回顾播客，我们必须回听我们自己的声音。我们锁定了几句台词，现在你们拿这个来取笑我。显然，在某一集里，我说，我在给你赞美。现在他们三个取笑我。我们经常这么说。我在给你赞美。
You may speak now. I did not ever say you may speak now. You may tell that story now. Oh, no. Oh, OK. Thank you. Oh, no. All right.
你现在可以说话了。我从来没有说过你现在可以说话了。你现在可以讲那个故事了。哦，不。哦，好吧。谢谢。哦，不。好吧。
I have a fan question. Did they list their favorite books or was it all scripted to fit your characters? There are actually a lot of questions like this. Were the movies scripted? Were any of them are real movies all scripted? All scripted. I actually was talking to Kate Flannery last night on the phone and I asked her if any of her movies for her DVDs for the deserted island, thank you, were her own.
我有一个粉丝提问。他们列出的是他们最喜欢的书，还是全都是为了符合你们的角色而写好的剧本？其实有很多这样类似的问题。电影是有剧本的吗？它们之中有任何一部是真实的电影，还是全都有剧本？全都有剧本。我昨晚在电话里和凯特·弗兰内里聊天，我问她，为了荒岛准备的那些 DVD 电影，谢谢，里面有没有她自己的。
And she said, no, they were all scripted. And I asked her because Meredith says, my big fat Greek wedding, and in real life, Kate Flannery and Nea Vardalos, who wrote that movie and stars in it, are very, very good friends. So I thought maybe she had improvised that, but nope, they were all scripted. Oh, wow. That was some good, good little trivia there. What was that?
她说，没有，全都是剧本写好的。我问她是因为梅雷迪思说《我的盛大希腊婚礼》，而在现实生活中，凯特·弗兰内里和妮娅·瓦达洛斯——也就是写这部电影并主演它的那个人——是非常非常好的朋友。所以我以为她可能是即兴发挥的，但并没有，全都是剧本写好的。哦，哇。那里有一些很好的冷知识。那是什么？
That was good trivia. Angela, you're giving you a compliment. Angela, you had decent trivia. I have always loved Rain's reaction to the firefighters. Yes. When he punches the air. I remember it on the day. I remember it fondly every time I watch it.
那是很有趣的冷知识。安吉拉，你在给你赞美。安吉拉，你的冷知识还不错。我一直很喜欢雷恩对消防员的反应。是的。当他向空中挥拳时。我当天就记得。每次我看的时候我都满怀深情地记起它。
And there was a fan question. Both Andrea and Thomas, two different people, not together, asked, did you guys recruit an actual fire department for this episode? The answer is yes. Yes, we did. And their uniforms are the Scranton uniforms so that they wanted them to look like Scranton firefighters, but they were in fact an actual firehouse here in Los Angeles. From what I understand, our wardrobe department reached out to the Scranton fire department
还有一个粉丝提问。安德里亚和托马斯两个人，不是一起的，都问了，你们这一集是找了真正的消防部门吗？答案是肯定的。是的，我们找了。他们的制服是斯克兰顿的制服，所以他们希望他们看起来像斯克兰顿的消防员，但实际上他们是洛杉矶当地的一个真正的消防局。据我所知，我们的服装部门联系了斯克兰顿消防局
and they sent in photos of their uniforms so they could recreate them. Yeah. That's very cool. All right, guys, I think we should take a break and then we will be back and then we will finish talking about the episode. See, this is what she does. Do you hear it? You know what, you guys?
他们发来了他们制服的照片，以便我们可以重新制作。是的。这太酷了。好了，伙计们，我觉得我们应该休息一下，然后我们会回来，接着把这一集聊完。看，这就是她做的事。你听到了吗？你知道吗，你们？
You get to have a break now. I am giving you permission to have a break. I am giving you a break. Okay, we're back from break and I do want to tell you guys that our days where we come in and edit are some of my favorite days because Jenna and I just crack up and it kind of reminds me of how we were on set. I agree. I agree.
你们现在可以休息了。我批准你们休息。我让你们休息。好了，我们从休息中回来了，我确实想告诉你们，我们来这里剪辑的日子是我最喜欢的日子之一，因为我和安吉拉总是笑得前俯后仰，这有点让我想起我们在片场的时候。我同意。我同意。
We just listened to each other and we're like, oh my God, is that what I sound like? It is not easy to listen to yourself for long periods of time though. With your best friend. It's made me very self-conscious. Oh, wait, Sam is waving at us. Sam is waving from the bootman. What, Sam? Maniacally waving.
我们只是听着对方，然后我们就想，哦天哪，我听起来就是这样的吗？不过，长时间听自己的声音可不容易。和最好的朋友一起。这让我变得非常自我意识过剩。哦，等等，萨姆在向我们挥手。萨姆在录音室里挥手。什么，萨姆？疯狂地挥手。
Hi, guys. Hi. What, Sam? So it looks like you both have stumbled upon a pretty big internet debate on whether or not it's desert or deserted islands. Oh, tell us more. It actually looks like both are correct because both stem from the same Latin word, which means abandoned or deserted.
嗨，伙计们。嗨。什么，萨姆？所以看起来你们两个偶然发现了一场相当大的互联网辩论，关于到底是“desert island”还是“deserted island”。哦，多告诉我们一些。其实看起来两个都是正确的，因为它们都源自同一个拉丁词，意思是“被抛弃的”或“荒废的”。
Okay. So both are technically correct. Okay, fine. But I also feel affirmed that it's a big debate. Yeah. I think it's one of those cases where everyone's right. Yes, it's not a woofle ball moment. No, it's not.
好吧。所以从技术上讲两者都是正确的。好吧，好吧。但我也感到很欣慰，这是一个很大的辩论。是的。我觉得这是那种每个人都对的情况。是的，这不是一个开玩笑的时刻。不，不是的。
It is not. But maybe. No one agrees on that. Well, maybe in parts of Texas you play woofle ball. You know what I'm saying? Okay, let's get back to the episode. A big part of this episode happens between Michael and Ryan. So there's almost two storylines.
不是的。但也说不定。没有人对此达成一致。好吧，也许在德克萨斯的部分地区你们会玩空气棒球。你知道我在说什么吗？好吧，让我们回到这一集。这一集很大一部分发生在迈克尔和瑞安之间。所以几乎有两条故事线。
There's the Michael, Ryan storyline and Dwight being jealous, and then there's the group of us who are all just trying to keep ourselves occupied in the parking lot. So during those scenes with Michael and Ryan in the car, all of us were just standing in the background for hours and hours. Hours. Your ears are getting sunburned. And do you remember that bug, Jenna? You know I remember that bug.
一条是迈克尔、瑞安的故事线和德怀特的嫉妒，然后还有我们这群人，大家都在停车场里想方设法打发时间。所以在车里拍摄迈克尔和瑞安的那些场景时，我们所有人都只是在背景里站了好几个小时。好几个小时。你们的耳朵都晒伤了。你还记得那只虫子吗，詹娜？你知道我记得那只虫子。
You know I screamed and ruined a take because of that bug. So guys, there was this bug. I looked it up online. It was as big as a bird. I said it was as big as a Buick. It was bright green and I looked it up. They're called Green June Beatles. Yeah, look it up because this thing is huge and it kept buzzing around us in the background
你知道我因为那只虫子尖叫并毁了一个镜头。所以伙计们，当时有这样一只虫子。我在网上查了一下。它有一只鸟那么大。我说它有一辆别克车那么大。它是亮绿色的，我查过了。它们叫绿六月甲虫。是的，查一下，因为这东西太大了，它一直在我们背景里嗡嗡地飞来飞去
and we would have to pretend like it wasn't there because we didn't want to be flailing in the background and ruin all the shots that Steve and BJ were working so hard on in the back of that car. Yes, there was a tree not too far from us, that little tree. And the dude was hanging out in that tree. But every once in a while he would buzz by and then literally though you could hear it. It sounded like a hummingbird or like some toy flying device. And it would come and land on Angela's head in particular.
我们得假装它不存在，因为我们不想在背景里挥舞手臂，毁掉史蒂夫和 BJ 在那辆车后座上辛辛苦苦拍的所有镜头。是的，离我们不远有一棵树，那棵小树。那家伙就在那棵树上呆着。但每隔一段时间它就会飞过来，字面意义上你能听到它的声音。听起来像一只蜂鸟或者某种玩具飞行器。它会飞过来，特别是停在安吉拉的头上。
It really liked Angela. I think, well here's the thing. You asked what we did between our break, right? You went and worked on that 70 show and have gossip you don't want to tell us. I was very much on a budget. I went back to working at the improv theater I was working at. I needed to, when we were going back to work, I needed to get my hair dyed because my hair, I'm like a sort of a dirty blonde, a dishwater blonde.
它真的很喜欢安吉拉。我想，事情是这样的。你问我们休息的时候做了什么，对吧？你去拍那个《70 年代秀》了，还有不想告诉我们的八卦。我当时手头很紧。我回去做我以前做过的即兴剧院的工作。我们需要，当我们准备回去工作时，我需要去把头发染一下，因为我的头发，我有点像那种脏金色，洗碗水般的金色。
And I decided to dye my hair myself to save the money because it's really expensive. So I went to the drugstore and I got a home kit. And so actually, I remember people wrote in on the comments section at IMDB, which you should never look at. They wrote in and said, what happened, why is her hair so bleach blonde? My hair is so blonde. And I think that dang bug thought I was a flower. I dyed my hair myself.
为了省钱，我决定自己染发，因为真的很贵。所以我去了药妆店买了一套家用染发剂。实际上，我记得有人在 IMDb 的评论区留言，你们绝对不应该去看那个。他们留言说，怎么回事，为什么她的头发漂得这么金？我的头发太金了。我想那只该死的虫子以为我是一朵花。我自己染的头发。
Look at it. It's like, I think I burnt my scalp. Well, John Krasinski started then doing this bit where he was pretending to be the bug picking you up and carrying you away from all of us. And we'd be like, bye, Angela. And I'd be like, but he would like do this. He's so tall, first of all. He would like do his arms like, and then like attach to my shoulders and then carry you
你看它。就像是，我觉得我的头皮都被烧伤了。好吧，约翰·卡拉辛斯基当时开始表演这样一个桥段，他假装自己是那只虫子，把你抱起来，把你从我们所有人身边带走。我们会说，再见，安吉拉。我会说，但他的动作就像这样。首先他太高了。他会把手臂做出那种姿势，然后像这样扣住我的肩膀，把你
away and like drop me off. But here's the thing, guys. I do not like people scaring me. We've discussed this. I like swat or hit. I also don't like anything near my ears. My ears were already sunburned and this thing would buzz by my ears and I would shriek and flail about.
带走，然后把我放下。但事情是这样的，伙计们。我不喜欢别人吓我。我们讨论过这个。我会拍打或反击。我也不喜欢任何东西靠近我的耳朵。我的耳朵本来就已经晒伤了，这东西还在我的耳朵旁边嗡嗡飞，我会尖叫并挥舞手臂。
And I think I did ruin the take. And then I remember that John as a joke decided to come up right next to your ear and pretend to be the bug. Make the buzz noise. And you were so startled, you hit him in the face. I hit him as hard as I could. I didn't know I was going to be hitting John. No, you had your thing.
我想我确实毁了那个镜头。然后我记得约翰开玩笑说，决定走到你的耳边假装是那只虫子。发出嗡嗡的噪音。你吓坏了，直接打了他的脸。我狠狠地打了她。我不知道我会打到约翰。不，你有你的反应。
You had your reaction. So a lot was going on in the background. I have a question, because at 16 minutes, 12 seconds, you guys, Roy is waving about like David Dynman is waving his hand back and forth and he kind of jumps up and down and I couldn't help but wonder if it was the bug. That's amazing. I have to talk about the talking head where we learned that Michael lost all of his money in a pyramid scheme.
你有了你的反应。所以在背景里发生了很多事。我有一个问题，因为在 16 分钟 12 秒时，伙计们，罗伊挥舞着手就像大卫·戴曼来回挥手一样，他有点上下跳跃，我忍不住想这会不会是那只虫子。太棒了。我得聊聊那个说话镜头，我们在那里得知迈克尔在一个传销骗局中输光了所有的钱。
And he says it was okay because it taught him more than he could have learned in business school. Yes. It was just, I have nothing to say about it except for that I thought it was a great talking head. I know. Well, Michael has a line in this episode for me that is just one of those lines that sums up Michael.
他说这没关系，因为它教给他的东西比他在商学院学到的还要多。是的。这只是，我对此无话可说，除了我认为这是一个非常棒的说话镜头。我知道。好吧，迈克尔在这一集里有一句台词对我来说就是那种概括了迈克尔的台词。
Michael is in Ryan's car in the backseat with Ryan. Ryan feels totally uncomfortable, the majority of this episode. But Michael says to Ryan, I became a salesman because of people. I love making friends. Oh. Oh. He probably was a good salesman but he's horrible in management because he doesn't get to like, you know, butter up strangers.
迈克尔坐在瑞安的车里，和瑞安坐在后座。瑞安在这一的大部分时间里都感到非常不舒服。但迈克尔对瑞安说，我成为推销员是因为人。我喜欢交朋友。哦。哦。他可能是一个不错的推销员，但他在管理上糟透了，因为他不喜欢，你知道的，去拍陌生人的马屁。
Well, we see him be a great salesman in future episodes. So he was very good at that and then got promoted to manager and now I think he's lonely. My next fan question has to do with the scene where Dwight is pouting in his car. Oh, yes. Let's do that because I have a card about that. Great. So Lucy asked, how many takes did it take for the scene where you and John are helping Dwight with his emotions when he's listening to REM in his car?
好吧，我们在以后的剧集里看到他是一个很棒的推销员。所以他在这方面非常擅长，然后被晋升为经理，现在我觉得他很孤独。我的下一个粉丝问题与德怀特在车里生闷气的场景有关。哦，是的。我们聊聊那个，因为我有一张关于那个的卡片。太好了。所以露西问，你和约翰帮助德怀特处理情绪——当他在车里听 REM 的时候——那个场景拍了多少条？
Rain seems to almost break at the end of that scene. Are you and John's reactions authentic or scripted? Well, it took a lot of takes. I'll say that. We spent a lot of time on that scene. I'm sorry. You were probably in the background with the bug on that one, Angela. I was probably fending for my life back there.
雷恩在那个场景结束时好像快要笑场了。你和约翰的反应是真实的还是剧本安排的？嗯，拍了很多条。我得这么说。我们在那个场景上花了很多时间。抱歉。安吉拉，你当时可能在背景里和虫子搏斗吧。我当时可能在后面为生存而战。
Me and Roy, apparently. And yes, I think rain is almost breaking. I think rain is almost breaking at the end, but I actually wrote this and I know my jam people out there are not going to be happy. But I said at 14, 22 seconds, I thought Jim and Pam were being mean to Dwight. I agree. When I watched this episode, I didn't like us. I didn't like you guys there either.
我和罗伊，显然是这样的。是的，我觉得雷恩快要笑场了。我觉得雷恩在最后快要笑场了，但我实际上写了这个，我知道我的“杰姆”粉丝们不会高兴。但我在 14 分钟 22 秒时说，我觉得吉姆和帕姆对德怀特太刻薄了。我同意。我看这一集的时候，我不喜欢我们。我也不喜欢你们当时的表现。
In fact, Jim suggests that he quits. Yeah. You know? I didn't like it. I didn't care for it. And then you guys laugh as you walk away. And here's the thing. I don't mind when you do pranks in the office because Dwight is so ridiculous and he takes
事实上，吉姆建议他辞职。对吧。你知道吗？我不喜欢那样。我不太喜欢。然后你们走开时还在笑。事情是这样的。我不介意你们在办公室里恶作剧，因为德怀特太荒谬了，而且他把
himself way too seriously. But in this episode, his feelings had been hurt and he was feeling sad and kind of rejected. Yeah. And I thought you guys were doing like jokes at his expense. And I didn't like it. Me either. I thought we crossed a line. Yep.
自己看得太重了。但在这一集里，他的感情受到了伤害，他感到难过和某种程度上的被拒绝。是的。我觉得你们是在拿他的痛苦开玩笑。我不喜欢这样。我也是。我觉得我们有点过分了。没错。
You know, something that I like about our show is that we were whole characters. And as people in your whole life, you probably aren't great every moment, right? Well, you have moments you're not proud of that you were like, you know what? I could have been better in that moment. Yes. And I thought Jim and Pam could have been better in that moment. Yeah. I was disappointed in them.
你知道，我喜欢我们剧的一点是，我们是完整的人物。作为活生生的人，你可能做不到每时每刻都很好，对吧？嗯，你会有一些让你引以为豪的时刻，你会觉得，你知道吗？我在那个时刻本来可以表现得更好。是的。我觉得吉姆和帕姆在那个时刻本来可以表现得更好。是的。我对他们感到失望。
And Emil also asked a couple of episodes ago, you mentioned that the cars we see your characters drive are sometimes your actual cars. Is the car that Dwight listens to? Everybody hurts. Yes. Is that Reigns actual car? No. That was a Dwight car.
埃米尔在几集前也问过，你提到过我们看到的你们角色的车有时是你们自己的真车。德怀特听《Everybody Hurts》的那辆车是雷恩的真车吗？不是。那是德怀特的车。
Yes. We bought that just for Dwight. And also Michael Sebring, they rented that just for Michael. That's right. And we only used our cars in some of those few first episodes. And really after that, I think we got a bigger budget. Yes. Pam had a Kia, I think for a while, and they rented that.
是的。那是专门为德怀特买的。还有迈克尔的赛百灵，那是专门为迈克尔租的。没错。我们只在前几集的某些时候用过自己的车。真的在那之后，我想我们有了更大的预算。是的。帕姆有一辆起亚，我想有一段时间是这样的，他们租了那辆。
So they rented all these cars for us. What about the warehouse guys breaking bottles? Yes. In the background. I have that on a card. So the warehouse guys look like they're smashing beer bottles. And you know what? It actually even annoys Roy, which is Roy's motivation to come over to you and be like,
所以他们为我们租了所有这些车。仓库的人砸瓶子是怎么回事？是的。在背景里。我卡片上有这个。所以仓库的人看起来像是在砸啤酒瓶。你知道吗？这实际上甚至让罗伊觉得烦恼，这也是罗伊走过来对你说，
gosh, you know, those warehouse guys, like he actually almost seemed vulnerable to me in that moment. He did. Like he didn't want to hang out with them. And I thought it was sort of weird that he was like, can I hang out with you guys? Yeah. Can you hang out with your own girlfriend? I think you can.
天哪，你知道，那些仓库的家伙——就像他在那一刻实际上看起来对我挺脆弱的。他确实。就像他不想跟他们一起混一样。我觉得他问“我能和你们一起吗”有点奇怪。是的。你能和自己的女朋友一起吗？我想你可以。
Yeah. Fiancé. Fiancé. Look, see. I know. I actually kind of liked seeing Roy like that. I liked seeing him. But then he so quickly is a turd again.
是的。未婚妻。未婚妻。看，瞧。我知道。我其实挺喜欢看到罗伊那样的。我喜欢看他那样。但他很快又变成了一个混蛋。
Well, I guess you did like seeing him, Angela, because during the game, who would you do? He says Angela. I didn't say Roy. No. No need to ask me. So the question under construction, who would Angela's character do Angela? Would it have been Dwight or Roy? It would have been a toss up.
好吧，我想你确实喜欢看他那样，安吉拉，因为在“你最想和谁上床”的游戏中。他说的是安吉拉。我没说罗伊。不。不需要问我。所以那个正在进行中的问题，安吉拉的角色会选谁？会是德怀特还是罗伊？这很难说。
I would have liked to see them fight over me and be titillated. And then I would have picked the winner. Well, all of the women say Jim, except for Pam. Pam says Oscar or Toby. Now, she's obviously saying this because she doesn't want to admit Jim. But in a later season, she does say she always thought Toby was cute, so maybe. If Toby had heard that, he would have maybe fainted. And then the whole time, Kevin, poor Kevin, is like standing right behind them.
我本想看他们为我争风吃醋，让我感到兴奋。然后我会挑选赢家。好吧，所有的女性都说吉姆，除了帕姆。帕姆说奥斯卡或托比。现在，她显然这么说是因为她不想承认是吉姆。但在后来的季里，她确实说过她一直觉得托比很可爱，所以也许吧。如果托比听到这个，他可能会晕倒。然后从头到尾，凯文，可怜的凯文，就像那样站在他们身后。
Meredith just sort of smiles like with this crazy eye look and nods her head at every single name. No, I did not. Yes. But did you notice that when they said who would you do, both Oscar and Kevin said Pam? At the same time. Wow. Jim says Pam.
梅雷迪思只是带着这种疯狂的眼神微笑，对每一个名字都点头。不，我才没有。是的。但你有没有注意到，当他们说你最想和谁上床时，奥斯卡和凯文都说了帕姆？同时。哇。吉姆说帕姆。
A lot of desire for Pam. And then, of course, everyone is saying who they would do. Jim says Kevin, and it's kind of playful and lighthearted. But then Michael says, I would love to have sex with Ryan. And everyone's like, Michael, you just took a turn. Yeah. That's not. When you put it that way, when you're playing these games, it just, it's like, no, no.
对帕姆有很强的渴望。然后，当然，每个人都在说他们想和谁上床。吉姆说凯文，这有点开玩笑和轻松。但接着迈克尔说，我很想和瑞安发生性关系。然后大家都说，迈克尔，你这就有点不对劲了。是的。那不对。当你这么说的时候，当你玩这种游戏时，它就像是，不，不。
You don't say, you don't say I would have sex with Toby. Like, no. You try. Yeah. Who would you do? Who would you do? I have some time codes, Jenna, that I want to get to before we come to the end of the episode.
你不能说，你不能说我想和托比上床。就像，不。你试着。是的。你最想和谁上床？你最想和谁上床？詹娜，我有一些时间码，我想在这一集结束前提到它们。
I know this takes us way back, but 11 minutes, 20 seconds, Michael has a talking head by the building. And if you watch it, you will see that Steve is squinting so badly. But you guys, when I watched that, I started laughing because I remember it was so bright out because it was so hot that we were all squinting. Like it was actually hard to. Except Devon with his sunglasses. Except Devon with his like super slick sunglasses.
我知道这把我们带回了很久以前，但 11 分钟 20 秒时，迈克尔在大楼旁有一个说话镜头。如果你看的话，你会看到史蒂夫眯着眼睛眯得厉害。但是伙计们，当我看到那个时，我笑了起来，因为我记得外面太亮了，因为天气太热了，我们都在眯着眼睛。就像这实际上很难。除了戴夫戴着太阳镜。除了戴夫戴着他那种超级酷炫的太阳镜。
But just watching Steve trying to keep his eyes open, it was so cracking me up. Also at 14 minutes, 54 seconds, who is that dude sitting on the curb across the street? He's by like a blue hatchback. He's just sitting on the curb watching us. Who is that guy? He's probably from one of the local businesses. I think so. I think he probably works at like, you know, the train yard.
但看着史蒂夫拼命想睁开眼睛，真的让我笑裂了。还有在 14 分钟 54 秒时，坐在街对面马路牙子上的那个家伙是谁？他旁边好像有一辆蓝色掀背车。他只是坐在马路牙子上看着我们。那家伙是谁？他可能是附近某家企业的员工。我想是的。我想他可能在类似于，你知道的，火车调度场工作。
They used to try to shut down the street when we were, when we, our cameras would swing that way, they would shut down the sidewalk or ask people not to walk, but we can't legally make you not. Also those guys at the junkyard could give zero. Zero Fs. Fs about it. It's true. He was having lunch.
当我们的摄像机转向那边时，他们曾经试图封锁街道，他们会封锁人行道或要求人们不要走，但我们不能在法律上强迫你不能走。还有垃圾场的那些家伙完全不在乎。完全不屑一顾。确实如此。他在吃午饭。
He's like, I'm going to sit here and watch what we're doing. What are these people swat bugs? Starting at 17 minutes, like 30 seconds, Michael can't find his phone. Right? Oh yeah. And so white runs back into the building. Runs back in. We're like, Dwight.
他就像是，我要坐在这里看他们在搞什么。这些人怎么回事，在拍虫子？从 17 分钟 30 秒开始，迈克尔找不到他的手机了。对吧？哦，是的。所以德怀特跑回大楼里。跑回去了。我们就像，德怀特。
But Ryan the temp is like, what if I call it? You know, right? Yeah. And there's this awkward exchange that like Michael's like, I gave you my number and he clearly didn't put it in his phone, but his phone is ridiculously old. And then Michael starts ringing in his pocket and do you know the song is playing? Yeah. Yeah.
但临时工瑞安却说，要不我打一个？你知道的，对吧？是的。然后有这样一个尴尬的交流，迈克尔说，我把我的号码给你了，而他显然没有把它存进手机里，但他的手机旧得离谱。然后迈克尔的口袋开始响铃，你知道在播什么歌吗？对，对。
Mambo number five. Mambo number five. Our writers were obsessed with that song, obsessed with it. And then that was like a really old flip phone. So you guys just a lot of old technology in this episode. Well this just goes to show you these were the phones of the time. Yeah. And then finally I upgraded to a blackberry.
《曼波第五号》。《曼波第五号》。我们的编剧对这首歌着迷了，简直着迷。然后那是一个非常旧的翻盖手机。所以伙计们，这一集里有大量的旧技术。好吧，这恰恰向你展示了这就是当时的手机。是的。然后我终于升级到了黑莓手机。
Yes, we had blackberries. Sometime at the end of season two. And that was the other thing. And I was thrilled that I could answer an email for my blackberry, but I still couldn't do any like web browsing. Also this episode I think shows the time it's in because if you had a group of people like this outside, there would not be only Oscar and Devin on a phone. Everybody would have their phones out.
是的，我们有黑莓手机。在第二季结束时的某个时候。那是另一回事。我很高兴我可以用我的黑莓手机回复电子邮件，但我仍然不能做任何网页浏览。还有这一集我认为展现了它所处的时代，因为如果你有一群这样的人在外面，绝对不会只有奥斯卡和德文在打电话。每个人都会把手机拿出来。
Oh yeah. That's what it would be now. Isn't that interesting? That's really interesting. And this episode wouldn't work. It wouldn't work because we wouldn't be forced to interact with one another. We wouldn't be playing games. We'd all just sit on our phones.
哦，是的。现在肯定会是这样。是不是很有趣？这真的很有趣。而且这一集就没法拍了。它行不通，因为我们不会被迫彼此互动。我们不会玩游戏。我们只会坐在那里玩手机。
Guys, we gotta get off the phone sometimes. This is a good point. And also remember Phyllis, our burlesque dancer at 19 minutes, three seconds. Guess who starts doing a little shimmy, a little dance to Dwight's song. But you know what this song is because guess who started the fire? Ryan started the fire. His cheese pita. What is a cheese pita?
伙计们，我们有时得放下手机。这是一个很好的观点。还有，还记得菲利斯吗，我们在 19 分钟 3 秒时的滑稽舞舞者。猜是谁开始随着德怀特的歌扭动身体，跳起了一小段舞。但你知道这首歌是什么吗，因为猜是谁引发了火灾？瑞安引发了火灾。他的奶酪皮塔饼。什么是奶酪皮塔饼？
I feel like I've had one. It's a pita with just cheese in it? Kind of. It kind of reminds me of like a pizza pocket. Like a hot pocket? A hot pocket. Okay. I thought it was a weird thing to a cheese pita.
我觉得我吃过。就是里面只有奶酪的皮塔饼？差不多。它有点让我想起比萨口袋。就像热口袋？热口袋。好吧。我觉得奶酪皮塔饼是个奇怪的东西。
I don't know. All right. I wonder if the writers ate them in the writer's room. They must have. Right. I have a fan question. The name of the person is one of those Marvel nerds. So one of those Marvel nerds asked, did Ryan started the fire get stuck in your head
我不知道。好吧。我想知道编剧们是不是在编剧室里吃过这个。他们一定吃过。对吧。我有一个粉丝问题。提问者的名字是那些漫威书呆子之一。所以其中一个漫威书呆子问，在拍摄这一集的过程中，“瑞安引发了火灾”这首歌一直在你脑子里挥之不去吗？是的。是的。四天后。
throughout filming this episode? Yes. Yes. Four days later. And every time I watch the episode, it gets stuck in my head for a whole rest of the day. So yes. Now I need to address something that I have some strong feelings about with this episode. We addressed one of my strong feelings, which is where I thought that Jim and Pam, we both
而且每次我看这一集，它都会一整天都在我脑子里挥之不去。所以是的。现在我需要谈谈我对这一集有一些强烈感受的事情。我们谈了我的一个强烈感受，就是我觉得吉姆和帕姆，我们都同意他们在对德怀特时表现得很糟糕。好吧。现在我必须说。
agreed they behaved poorly with Dwight. Okay. Now I have to say that. I'm really wondering if this is going to be what's, I'm hiding my last card from you. Yeah. I have one card left. And I have one sheet of paper left. Okay.
我在想这会不会是，我把最后一张卡片藏起来了。对。我剩下一张卡片了。我剩下一张纸了。好吧。
Okay. Katie arrives. Mm-hmm. She says that her Desert Island movies are legally blonde. That's all she gets out. Yes. And Jim cuts her off. And remember earlier, Pam.
好吧。凯蒂到了。嗯哼。她说她的荒岛电影是《律政俏佳人》。她只说了这些。是的。吉姆打断了她。还记得之前，帕姆。
Meredith had said it. And Pam said, I really liked that movie and Jim gave her trouble about it. And then she takes it back. Yeah. Okay. And then, which by the way, I don't like that. I don't like it that Pam took it back, that she changed herself. Yes.
梅雷迪思说过了。帕姆说，我真的很喜欢那部电影，吉姆为此找她麻烦。然后她又收回去了。是的。好吧。然后，顺便说一下，我不喜欢那样。我不喜欢帕姆把话收回去，她为了迎合别人而改变了自己。是的。
She edited. She edited herself. Uh-huh. In front of Jim. Uh-huh. That bumps me out. I don't like how Pam then snarkily laughs at Katie. When she says it.
她删减了。她删减了自己。嗯哼。在吉姆面前。嗯哼。这让我很不爽。我不喜欢帕姆随后冷笑着嘲笑凯蒂。当她说出那句话时。
I don't like it. I thought it was Katie. I thought it was competitive. And I know that she's jealous of Katie, but Pam likes legally blonde. So why can't she just say that to Jim? I know. She doesn't stand up for herself. And then she shames Katie for it because she's trying to look cool for Jim.
我不喜欢。我觉得那是凯蒂。我觉得这很有竞争性。我知道她嫉妒凯蒂，但帕姆明明很喜欢《律政俏佳人》。那她为什么不能直接对吉姆说呢？我知道。她没有为自己挺身而出。然后她因为想在吉姆面前显得很酷而为此羞辱凯蒂。
And I think it's a flaw. I do. But I like it because I think it shows Pam being human and complex, but it does make me cringe. I remember dating a guy in college, oh my God, he loved the show Bass Masters. Guys, I don't give a crap about, sorry, I don't, here's the thing. I appreciate that you want to get out in nature. I don't need to watch you fish.
我觉得这是一个缺点。确实是。但我喜欢它，因为我觉得它展现了帕姆作为人的真实和复杂，但它确实让我感到尴尬。我记得在大学里和一个男生约会，天哪，他超级喜欢《Bass Masters》这个节目。伙计们，我对——抱歉，我——事情是这样的，我明白你想去大自然。我不需要看你钓鱼。
No offense to the Bass Master people. But I would watch hours of Bass Master with this guy in college because I liked him. And I'm like, oh my God. I think that's different. I dated a guy. Well, I think you edited yourself. I think Pam, not Jenna, edited herself for Jim because she likes him. But what I don't like is that it was at the expense of Meredith.
对《Bass Masters》的人没有冒犯之意。但在大学里我会和这个男生看好几个小时的《Bass Masters》，因为我喜欢他。然后我想，哦天哪。我觉得这不一样。我约会过一个男生。好吧，我觉得你删减了你自己。我觉得帕姆，不是詹娜，为了吉姆删减了她自己，因为她喜欢他。但我不喜欢的是，这是以牺牲梅雷迪思为代价的。
You like, Jim judged Meredith's picks and then he judged you and then you judged Katie. Exactly. That's what I'm saying. Like that's the sort of behavior that I didn't like. I dated a lot of people where I took on their interests because I like them. I think that's love. You know? I will get up in the middle of the night and watch the World Cup with my husband because
你喜欢，吉姆对梅雷迪思的选择评头论足，然后他评判了你，然后你又评判了凯蒂。没错。这就是我想说的。就像那是那种我不喜欢的行为。我约会过很多人，我为了迎合他们而接受了他们的兴趣，因为我喜欢他们。我觉得那就是爱。你知道吗？我会半夜起床和我丈夫一起看世界杯，因为
he loves it. You know, I think that's cool. But anyway, after all of this happens, Pam kisses Roy in front of Jim. You want to see what I wrote? First of all, I said at 19 minutes, 52 seconds, we have some serious Pam sass happening. She laughs when Katie also says legally blonde. And then she says, what an adorable car. Which is basically Pam's moment of, looks like someone took the slow train to Philly.
他热爱这个。你知道，我觉得这很酷。无论如何，这一切发生后，帕姆在吉姆面前吻了罗伊。你想看看我写了什么吗？首先，我在 19 分钟 52 秒时说，我们看到了一些严重的帕姆式傲娇。当凯蒂也说《律政俏佳人》时，她笑了。然后她说，多可爱的车啊。这基本上就是帕姆的时刻，就像有人坐慢车去了费城一样。
This is Pam's moment, like she is being so snarky. I know. And then I put, and then Pam smooches Roy in front of everyone, tacky. Oh, you wrote tacky because I wrote, okay, I would do that. Tacky. I wouldn't throw like someone else's opinions under the bus and change all my way I think to impress a man. But I would try to make him jealous by kissing someone else.
这就是帕姆的时刻，她表现得太尖酸刻薄了。我知道。然后我写道，然后帕姆在每个人面前吻了罗伊，真俗气。哦，你写了“俗气”，因为我写了，好吧，我会那样做。俗气。我不会把别人的意见踩在脚下，为了给一个男人留下好印象而改变我的所有想法。但我会通过亲吻别人来让他吃醋。
Well, I said tacky. And I want to say two fans wrote in about this as well. Macy said, can we all agree that in this episode, Jim is completely wrong about legally blonde. It's a great movie. Everyone was right to pick it. And Chubby Bookworm said, why is Jim so opposed to a movie about a girl who is strong enough to go for what she wants and along the way finds herself and encourages others and up builds them and is capable and inspiring.
好吧，我写了俗气。而且我想说，有两位粉丝也为此写信了。梅西说，我们能一致认为在这一集中，吉姆对《律政俏佳人》的看法完全是错的吗？这是一部伟大的电影。每个人选它都是对的。而胖书虫说，为什么吉姆会如此反对一部关于一个足够坚强去追求她想要的东西、并在这一过程中发现自我、鼓励他人、激励他人、有能力且鼓舞人心的女孩的电影呢？
I agree. I think legally blonde is a great movie. It has a positive message. You heard it here. Jim is wrong. You heard it here. Reese Witherspoon. We got Reese Witherspoon in case you were worried that the movie did land.
我同意。我认为《律政俏佳人》是一部伟大的电影。它传递了积极的信息。你们在这里听到了。吉姆是错的。你们在这里听到了。瑞茜·威瑟斯彭。我们有瑞茜·威瑟斯彭，以防你们担心这部电影没有反响。
It landed. We loved it. And everyone, that is the fire. I want to leave you with this final moment. When Rain as Dwight sings the song in the conference room, he's holding up the charred cheese pita, whatever you can tell. When Rain gets through the whole thing, he's so happy. I want to know.
它有反响。我们很喜欢它。大家，那就是火灾。我想以这最后一个时刻结束。当雷恩饰演的德怀特在会议室里唱歌时，他举着烧焦的奶酪皮塔饼，随便什么你都能看出来。当雷恩唱完整首歌时，他是那么开心。我想知道。
I want to text Rain and ask him how many takes did he have to do because when he hits that final Ryan started the fire, he's like, he's like alive because I think it probably took a few takes to get it. I bet you're probably right. All right. Next week, everybody, we are going to be talking about Halloween with special guests. Yes, my neighbor and the delightful Creed Bratton. So be sure to join us for that.
我想给雷恩发短信问他拍了多少条，因为当他唱到最后那句“瑞安引发了火灾”时，他就像是，他就像是活过来了一样，因为我觉得这可能需要拍好几条才能做好。我打赌你可能是对的。好了。下周，各位，我们要和特邀嘉宾一起聊聊万圣节。是的，我的邻居和可爱的克里德·布拉顿。所以请务必加入我们。
And we'll see you soon. Okay. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
我们很快再见。好的。再见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。
For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要获取该节目的无广告版本和我们的花絮糖果包，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。